el motor del crecimiento mundial se
encuentra en una fase baja ya que las
restricciones se hacen sentir nuevos
datos muestran que la producción
manufacturera de china se contrajo en
abril por segundo mes consecutivo
alcanzando el nivel más bajo desde
principios del 2020 sin embargo los
expertos siguen siendo optimistas e
italia sin una vez controlada la
epidemia se eliminarán las barreras que
obstaculizan las cadenas de suministro
especialmente en la logística y se
liberada la demanda acumulada de todo el
mercado a gran medida la demanda
acumulada tras la reapertura de la
pandemia impulso a las economías
mundiales a recuperarse rápidamente el
año pasado pero se dispararon provocando
una mayor inflación la mayor economía
del mundo eeuu vio como su pib se redujo
inesperadamente los tres primeros meses
de este año a pesar de que el desempleo
alcanzó mínimos históricos
los ingresos ajustados a la inflación de
los consumidores siguen viéndose
reducidos por la inflación por lo tanto
cabe esperar que el crecimiento
económico pierda impulso durante la
última parte del año en la eurozona la
inflación ha subido un 75 % en el último
mientras los precios de los alimentos y
la energía se disparan agravados por la
guerra de ucrania la semana pasada el
fondo monetariointernacional bajó su
previsión de crecimiento para la región
en más de un punto porcentual hasta el
2,8 por ciento este año a causa de la
vulnerabilidad del bloque ante el
petróleo y el gas ruso